joining us on the line is Abigail
Shriver who new books the irreversible
damage the transgender crazy seducing
our daughter she's a frequent
contributor to The Wall Street Journal
and she has an ad from Columbia
University where she received the you
Rhetta Jay tell it fellowship n a
bachelor's in philosophy from the
University of Oxford as well as JD from
Yale Law School again that book is
irreversible damage so Abigail the book
is now out and it is currently being
censored by social media it is currently
being censored by Amazon which has said
that you're not allowed to advertise the
book obviously you've committed a great
violation and a great sin so give us the
update on what the social media networks
are doing to prevent the dissemination
of an important message here well so far
they're blocking and the ads my
publisher is not allowed to advertise so
if you do a search for my book we're
sorry if you do a search for you know
issues facing transgender girls or girls
identifying as transgender you will get
a series of ads promoting books that
that think this is wonderful and
celebrating it but they ban a book that
is skeptical that this is a very good
thing and have you heard any sort of
actual explanation from them about this
because obviously these are very much
open scientific issues to say the very
least like the notion that we have
discovered the cure for the suffering of
gender dysphoria and that in there and
variably wise in gender affirmation and
treating seven-year-old boys as seven
year old girls and treating them with
hormones when they're 14 this is a brand
new attempt that is being made by the by
many in the scientific community there
is no long term data available there's
some fairly good data that's being
ignored about the number of people who
are being given these sorts of
transitions and drugs or unhappy and are
transitioning back or who are saying
that they're unhappy there's some pretty
good stats about the the fact that
suicidality rates are still
extraordinarily high for people who are
who are post-transition so why exactly
what what are the messages that are
being given by social media to ban this
sort of message
well my usually it's called hate speech
of some sort even to discuss a
scientific issue of how are these girls
faring is it or is it helping them you
know mental distress is it alleviating
mental distress are they you know
engaging with
and and having community or are they
cutting off their parents and dropping
out of school so even talking about the
objective measures of how these girls
are doing is something apparently you're
not allowed to do my book specifically
they accused me of conversion therapy
around sexual orientation
now I interviewed a lot of lesbians and
other gay people you know gay men for
the book this book has nothing to do
with sexual orientation it just so
happens a lot of lesbians have a lot to
say about it because they believe that
many of them believe that these girls
would naturally be lesbian it is an
incredible attempt to conflate and you
have seen scientific bodies attempting
to suggest that conversion therapy on
gays and lesbians the same thing as
suggesting that a boy who says gives a
girl if you say to him no no you're
actually a boy and maybe we should
figure out a way for you to deal with
some of your feelings that this is now
conversion therapy that we are going to
treat sexual orientation in exactly the
same way we freed gender orientation
which is patently insane I mean these
are not the same thing at all maybe you
can talk a little bit about the
differences yeah it is really different
and here's why conversion therapy for
sexual orientation was you know involved
a lot of grisly practices and also
didn't work but but you know therapy to
help someone get comfortable in their
biological sex has long been practice
its enormous ly effective and in fact
that was the reason that for you for
decades and decades over 70% of kids who
experienced any gender dysphoria in
childhood would outgrow it
today in eighth I think it were up to 18
States actually banned so-called
conversion therapy even for gender
identity so that the therapist who wants
to help someone get comfortable in their
biological sex might lose their license
for doing that I mean they're the
crackdown on all of this obviously leads
to a lack of de systems how do we have
any long-term data on whether the
strategies that are supposedly
scientifically verified are successful
or not because there have been some
studies that suggest that gender
transition is is more successful than
non gender transition many of the
studies are very small sample size are
non longitudinal what have you you've
looked at the evidence what do you think
about the the treatments that are now
being presumed to be successful
generally so so one of the things that
they often say is that suicidality
is alleviated when when someone gender
transitions that is not clear at all
so that gets you know dramatically
exacerbated we I'm sorry exaggerated we
don't know that so that that either
gender dysphoria is the cause of
suicidality we don't know that nor do we
think that gender Dan Trent nor do we
have evidence that gender transition
will alleviate that what we do know is
that these girls suddenly identifying as
transgender and they are now the
dominant demographic what they're
experiencing doesn't look like gender
dysphoria at all so maybe you can
explain what exactly they are
experiencing and the differences between
typical symptom ology of gender
dysphoria and and what these girls are
going through right now because what you
talked about is rapid onset gender
dysphoria this kind of new symptom that
we've been seeing where one girl in a
particular social group will declare
that she is a boy and then all the other
girls in the social group will suddenly
declare that they too are boys that's
exactly right so we have a nearly
hundred year diagnostic history of
gender dysphoria and it was always
something that emerged in early
childhood ages two to four little boys
would say I'm not a boy call me a girl I
only want to wear girls clothes I know
him and they were very insistent about
it and and clearly felt severely
uncomfortable being boys today out of
nowhere the dominant demographic is
teenage girls with no childhood history
and in fact when you when you to ask
them and Lisa Lippmann the public health
research researcher did the work the
research on this when you asked them why
did they come to this their answer is
very often tied to social media they
discovered it with friends or they
discovered it on the Internet this is
not how traditional gender dysphoria
emerges hey so when we talk about you
know the possibility of treating people
for you know rapid onset gender
dysphoria or the prevalence of distance
here you know what what does treatment
like that look like I think people have
this vision when we talk about clinic
conversion therapy that is wildly
outdated by the way even outdated with
regard to sexual orientation I mean
there's they're sort of this perception
that taking even with even if you
believe this is ineffective the
identification of sexual orientation
quote-unquote conversion
therapy with what it was 50 years ago or
who were being electro-shocked in summer
camp as opposed to now you go talk to a
doctor or a priest or something who's
basically engaging in cognitive
behavioral therapy I mean even if you
believe that's ineffective the attempt
to conflate the two is ridiculous to
conflate that with regard to you know
how people are treated now with regard
to gender identity disorder or gender
dysphoria is it's completely ridiculous
what does that look like I mean how
typically have priests religious
authorities and doctors treated kids who
aren't coming in with gender dysphoria
so the way they treated them was by
something called watchful waiting kensic
are really pioneered this is a wonderful
psychologist so I interviewed many times
and what he would do is he looked at the
whole child and he would often say and
this was widely practiced you know
gender dysphoria they may be expressing
discomfort in their sex but sometimes
the problem is not their sex sometimes
they have a parent who's not giving them
attention until they dress as the
opposite sex where they feel a parent
withdraw and only get happy with them
when they look or seem like a girl so
they would sort of both try to get the
root of the child's distress and in some
cases no therapy was required at all
because over time a child would
naturally outgrow it this was this was
not something that needed a dramatic
intervention nor did it ever get one
we're speaking about the book
irreversible damage the transgender
craze seducing our daughters by Abigail
Schreyer the censorship of the book is
in and of itself an amazing story
especially because it seems like it is
priests aging something even more
dangerous which would be not only the
inability to even get out a message
contrary to the popular message that the
only solution to any symptomology or
even claim of gender dysphoria is
surgery and hormone treatment which is
dramatic dramatic stuff but also it if
you yourself our parents I think this is
the next step is that if you are a
parent and your child is at school and
reports gender dysphoria and goes home
and you say well we are going to use
watchful waiting we are going to wait
and see if this is if this is persistent
or if it's assess that you will then be
dragged up before Child Protective
Services and you could lose your kid it
feels like this is the predictable next
step and I think we're gonna see in the
UK and Canada and then finally
in the united states of miss continues
remember that already teaching schools
are not telling the parents so in
california this is certainly true they
actually have forms they fill out in
which if a child is after being
encouraged steeped in gender ideology
and encouraged to come out as one other
gender than than their biological sex
the parents these schools will then fill
out a form ask them their gender their
their new name and pronouns and the
school will keep that from the parents
we do this in california they do this in
New York and New Jersey I've been told
by parents I know New York's very open
about it so already the undermining of
parental authority on this issue is is
is very strong and a very extreme in
fact in California we have something
called spiritual abuse which is written
into the California framework and that's
when someone and kids are taught this if
someone tries to based on religion make
you conform to their idea of biological
sex so they're already being told that
their parents are abusers if they don't
go along with this this is deeply scary
stuff pick up the new book it's
irreversible damage the transgender
crisis is using our daughters don't pay
attention to social media that's
censoring it instead go by the book it's
still available at Amazon right they
just want to let you to advertise it it
is for now okay so we'll see how long it
is before Amazon G platforms it the good
news is there's still alternative
markets available at least for the
moment
Abigail's fryer thanks so much for
joining the show really appreciate your
courage on this issue thanks Alex
this video is sponsored by blinks L it
is the revolutionary invoicing software
for small businesses spend less time
billing more time making the money with
bling sale go down to the link in our
description and give it a click